good afternoon my name is Patrice my
lungs and it's a pleasure to be here
with you this afternoon this is a unique
opportunity for me as it's one of the
first presentations that Clara tots
genomics has had the opportunity to
present to you all about the company who
we are what we're doing and it's it's an
exciting time to give you a little bit
of a background on myself I'm Patrice
Milo's i joined clara toss in May of
this year joining as the chief executive
officer of claret oz genomics we are a
pediatric molecular genetics company
focus very much on integrating
cutting-edge next-generation sequencing
technology with our ability to diagnose
and lead to new treatments for pediatric
disease so I'll be telling you about
that today my overview of my
presentation is such that I'll talk a
little bit about why pediatric genetics
is so important today what's unique
about it um overlay that with the
exponential increase that we've seen in
sequencing technologies that have
enabled us to be where the field is
today along with our growing knowledge
of the application of that technology to
the field are the knowledge the growing
knowledge of the field of human disease
genetics as well as the now evolving use
of genetic testing much of which is what
has been described or going on in the
conference to which you are
participating and listening and then our
ability to translate that knowledge that
we are generating with our positions for
pediatric healthcare and a real
understanding
the key differentiators of who Claire
tossed genomics is just so you know I
will be attempting to address questions
at various points throughout the
presentation although since this format
is new to me I'll see how that goes as
we move along so I think I start with
this slide because it really begins to
describe why the time is now for the
application of pediatric molecular
diagnostics and it really results from
the fact that our knowledge of human
disease genetics is rapidly growing and
if you look at this data that was
recently published in the Canadian
Journal of Cardiology it shows you a
nice representation of the variants that
have been reported in the human gene
mutation database and the exponential
increase of that knowledge with now
variants reported in hgmd far exceeding
ten thousand on variants the majority of
those which lead to a disease causation
in an individual who carries those a
rare or a mutation in a particular
disease gene I was struck by the
knowledge that we are gaining in our
understanding of human disease genetics
when I read two papers that appeared in
science express in during the month of
july in which to science express
articles were published online in which
gene therapy was used to correct two
different disease and syndromes in young
children now granted these were gene
therapy using a lentil viral infection
transduction of lube hladik stem cells
in only three patients in the case of
the wiskott-aldrich syndrome and
another syndrome that I'll describe but
what was amazing to me was the fact that
we knew the mutation that existed in
these patients in the case of W I asked
this is an inherited immunodeficiency
caused by mutations in the gene encoding
WA SP approaching regulating the
cytoskeleton which leads to extremely
debilitating and early loss of
children's lives that have this
condition in this gene therapy
correction however correction of the
genetic back following stem-cell
transaction with a wild-type wa.s
protein allowed the correction and
production of this protein which was
deficient as you'll see in patient one
two and three above the mutation in the
wis was exonic in the case of the first
individual resulting in an amino acid
change a deletion and also another amino
acid change which resulted in expression
of the protein at levels on less than
five percent of what would be expected
in those young infant children um the
stem cell to death transduction of cells
isolated from a bone marrow resulted in
a very high efficiency of transduction
of the wild-type protein at vector copy
numbers that ranged between one and
three copies per genome of these
children following re introduction into
the child and then on production as
you'll see in the graph represented on
the bottom of near on normal levels of
expression of the WA s protein in both
lymphocytes and platelets in these
children's an amazing effect that is
seen and granted only three children
however when we think about the
correlation of understanding who the
child is with the genetic defect and our
ability to
subsequent correct that defect with
expression of the wild-type protein it
just represented a remarkable
publication for me as I took on this new
role as CEO for Claire tossed genomics
the same again in the same science
express for metachromatic like
leukodystrophy this is a major license
or a handed life is normal lysosomal
storage disease caused by a RS a
deficiency that results in the
myelination of neurons of the brain and
major loss of neuromotor function and
again near the inability of these
children to to progress and function and
an early death for these children again
three patients I'm showing the genetic
correction of these proteins now
introduced in bone marrow a reproduction
of the ARS a on the lysosomal storage
defect correction and what you see most
remarkably on the bottom right hand is
the brain morphology of one of the
patients on following some twenty five
months of gene therapy where you have
near normal images radiological images
of the brain and on the far right the
debilitating brain on pathology
histology of a child who would be
progressing normally with this disease
so again remarkable correction in the
ability to deliver a wild-type protein
to normally deficient patients in this
case only three but again remarkable
findings so what I'd like to do is just
give you a view of you know what has
happened since really the achievements
of the Human Genome Project delivered in
the early on 2000 time frame and where
we are today clearly
course that we are after at Clara's
genomics is our ability to use this
information for really translating and
it's better informing patient care in
our pediatric patient population and we
have a firm belief that the time is now
to translate this to our positions and
to the bedside clearly the historical
perspective as early as 1902 a disorder
of metabolism of phenylalanine and
tyrosine was identified with inborn
errors of metabolism by a physician
Archibald Gerard at the time where it
was known a disorders of joints and
heart valves curious darkening of the
urine which was the result of the
metabolic disorder in that patient on
treatment with dietary restriction
allowed you to restore the unbeatable
ISM and that was an early as 1902
without a clear understanding of the
genetic basis of that technology
combined with our knowledge II a
phenotype obviously technology
advancements have been staggering if we
look at the plot provided by National
Human Genome Research Institute the
dramatic decline in the cost of
sequencing per genome has truly been
staggering and this was coupled at a
time with the ability to introduce
next-gen sequencing and our ability to
use that at a research scale that has
been really bringing the cost down
however i think there's also a pause
that's needed at this time in thinking
about not only the cost per base but
also the level of cost and accuracy
that's needed for translating this into
clinical information sequencing of the
Mendelian obviously has been occurring
over the last few years this was an
initial publication by Stephen King's
more which talked about carrier testing
for severe childhood recessive diseases
using next-generation sequencing
published a little bit over
two years ago sequencing exomes of known
gene sequencing of an exome interpreting
regions of interest for recessive
childhood diseases again very much in a
research mode for a research discovery
of those on mutations again sequencing
to diagnose rare disorders this was a
dysmorphic syndrome of which exome
sequencing again by colleagues Deborah
Nickerson Jay shuddery like Sarah neg at
Washington University really identified
the cause of a Mendelian disorder in in
this these two individuals again using
exome sequencing and that really has
just saw breast now with more and more
of novel gene discoveries causative
mutations being found in these rare
individuals that present with unique
phenotypes and that will just continue
with a research exome and now clinical
exome is truly coming into therefore are
both gene discovery and that rapid
trajectory that we saw in the first
slide where numerous rare Mendelian
disorders are now being elucidated on an
ever ongoing basis um I'm just going to
pause just to see if there are any
questions no questions at this point so
let's move on so the question really
that we eclair toss poses how do we
translate discoveries of the genetic
cause of disease such as a basis of
disease to our patients and really a
broad audience of not only children but
adults as well and so it really enters
the realm of genetic testing so today
the American Medical Association
classifies genetic testing in three
different categories diagnostic testing
whether an individual has a genetic
disease and today we estimate that there
are more than 4,000 diseases that are
caused by single gene mutations and the
rapid elucidation of those I think today
we probably have well over 1500 if not
two thousand genes that are now known to
be caused by five um single gene
mutations and what those mutations are
predictive medicine determining whether
an individual has an increased risk for
a particular disease is another
classification and then pharmacogenomics
obviously an area of great interest this
is an area where I'd spent a great deal
of time in my prior um careers um
starting the pharmacogenomics group
advisor pharmaceuticals in 1996 and
really working with colleagues advisor
to actually implement and begin to think
about how this could be used not only in
drug development but also in drug
discovery and understanding how you
tailor an individual's genetic makeup to
whether a drug is suitable for a
particular patient and what would be the
safest and most efficacious dose and
clearly there's a growing interest in
this area now and I think more and more
pharmaceutical companies today are
embracing this combined with all the
genetic elucidation of disease and
pharmacogenomics is the opportunity to
use molecular testing and we see a
tremendous increase in the diseases for
which testing is available today that
disease number is closely approaching if
not already approaches 3,000 and the
number of laboratories shown in the
lower portion has pretty much remained
steady during the course of probably the
last five to seven years what's
interesting is you see many laboratories
entering the space on leading the space
but a study group of companies that are
working in a CLIA setting on attempting
to use molecular
testing for either diagnosing disease or
oncology in particular but it is
definitely an active area of investment
and also on clinical utility the ability
and the use of genetic testing obviously
more than 1,200 genetic tests are
available to the physicians to aid in
diagnosis and therapeutic decisions for
again over a thousand diseases and I'd
say that's even significantly more
genetic testing is performed for a
variety of reasons on confirming the
diagnosis of symptoms pre-symptomatic
testing for estimating risk we see an
increase in prenatal diagnostic
screening nets and driven again very
much by next-generation sequencing and
companies like Sequenom and a variety of
other testing methodologies what's
interesting is the cost and complexity
for the average physician are increasing
on some Sanger tests today can be more
than fifteen thousand dollars an even
single gene tests can be pricing upwards
of fifty nine hundred dollars a clinical
exome can cost 75 hundred dollars a
clinical genome give me twelve thousand
dollars getting an answer may not be
definitive and in some cases the rate of
getting a successful answer may be only
twenty-five percent so what we're seeing
is there's cost pressures in the
healthcare system to contain these costs
but yet we know how valuable they can be
so Claire tossed genomics has entered
this space because we see an important
opportunity to build not just one
company but a company that represents a
pediatric network across the pediatric
community to really help pediatric
physicians to better diagnose and
understand disease of patients
so a little background on who we are
what we do is really will follow we are
a clinical pediatric genetic testing
laboratory we have been in existence as
a a clia-certified genetic diagnostic
laboratory operating within Boston
Children's Hospital for um well over ten
years we are now launched as an
independent company i'll talk more about
that but our goal really is the best
quality services from helping a
physician to decide what do i order here
are the symptoms of my patient how do I
confirm these symptoms through an
understanding with client services
around pre-ordering all the way through
testing and then a quality of an
interpretive genomic post report given
back to that position we test for a
whole variety of conditions they're
available on our website or test menu
found there I'll talk about a few of
those I think what makes Claire toss
genomics unique as a genetic diagnostic
laboratory is the close partnership we
have built with the clinical and genetic
expertise from pediatric hospitals for
test development and for interpretation
of results that emerge from our test for
flings we offer single gene tests we
offer gene panels and today to the
Boston Children's Hospital community we
offer research exomes although the goal
is clinical exomes at some point when we
view the time is right we also have a
fascinating and a proprietary copy
number variation test in a clinical
laboratory with a special emphasis on
autism spectrum disorders that I'll talk
about later we are optimizing our
testing laboratory for the light
technologies ion proton platform for our
next gen sequencing that will be
scalable and offered and i'll talk more
about
with you so what Clara toss again aims
to do is build a network through our
services and really focusing on an
interface that enables our community to
really address the challenges an
opportunity of clinical use of next-gen
sequencing that is this is a major
investment that Boston Children's
Hospital could not do alone there's a
complexity of the measurement there's a
complexity of the interpretation there's
an understanding of the optimal clinical
utility how do we utilize this
information how do we build a consensus
around reimbursement that these tests
are important that we really offer an
optimal clinical report for our
physicians and their patients we provide
support services and exploration and
also a forum for discovery so it's
really focused on the right question the
right test and the right answer for
patients our management team and our key
members myself is the chief executive
officer bring more than 18 years of
pharmaceutical experience and experience
of genomics and medicine my passion has
really driven me to be at the cutting
edge of technology as it applies to
medicine I bring Pharma experience but I
also spent on greater than four years as
the chief scientific officer at gila
Coast Biosciences buzzing a molecule DNA
sequencing company that really found the
marriage of my passion with medicine and
next-gen sequencing Mary Ellen court
asus has worked at Boston Children's
Hospital overseeing the clinical
laboratory management and operations
here at Boston Children's and now with
us at Clara toss and was a co-founder
Mirjana Bachman is our chief business
officer years of experience as a
business development director
specializing in corporate collaborations
with a co-founder and then key partners
with us Peter Park Tim you some of the
world's foremost experts in medical
informatics visionary leaders
informatics experts Tim you a practicing
physician who sees patients and knows
just what our data can do for his
patients and then my good colleague
David margulies he and I have worked
together in years past has really been
an entrepreneur in the medical and
information systems on community he
found a corrosion diagnostic founder of
Cerner care insight which was later sold
to form on WebMD and is a co-founder of
Clara tossed genomics he sits on our
board he remains at Boston Children's
Hospital as the executive director of
the Jade partnership initiative our
board of directors as chaired by Bob
Higgins a well-known unsuccessful
venture on capital of individual at
Highland Capital and has done much in
the health care community is a professor
of Harvard Business School and just a
great colleague to work with David
Ronnie Andrews sits on the board of
directors it was president of medical
sciences at life technologies as the
former CEO of claret Clariant Clariant
and a life long career in the medical
diagnostic community brings much
intellectual capital know how leadership
and everything to our board and myself
and then we have board observers Eric
Alverson well-known in the Boston
community and innovation a director of
Tito at PCH and mark Gardner from life
technologies our funding and how we
arose really we arose out of Boston
Children's Hospital DNA diagnostic
laboratory again a successful history of
over ten years in a CLIA certified
laboratory offering DNA services that is
really unknown to the external community
and our job is to really tell the story
build a partnership and build a network
where we can bring what we do to the
broader pediatric community we have
major investments from life technologies
and other investments on going and
building partnerships with major
pediatric cost
in the US and we're also actively
working to partner with community or
country health centers excuse me as we
take our knowledge not just to the US
but also countries who are interested in
what we do so what does the pediatric
community want today and I think I look
at it from a from an ecosystem of
patients clinicians hospitals payers
researchers and health systems the
patient wants a fast reliable answer
clinicians want support streamlined
processes hospitals really need to
understand and want a one-stop shop that
provides the best value integrated
reporting and makes it easy for them to
offer the best product to their patients
for service payers want utility and
value and also obviously the research
community wants a large number of well
characterized samples that are scalable
to enable discovery so how do we address
these needs eclair toss as we think
about the most important is the
pediatric hospitals they really want
cost-effective cutting-edge measurements
that they know provide reliable accurate
interpretation for the patient they want
partners who can able the pediatric
hospitals and our peers to build
knowledge and advanced medical genomics
for our pediatric patients and it's
important because the pediatric
community is very different than the
adult community because in many cases if
you can diagnose earlier the signs and
translate that into a clear diagnosis
for your patient it leads to better
treatment better patient management and
better outcomes so again needing patient
needs and let's go through this so for
the patients it's really a fast reliable
answer genetic testing with consistent
interpretation
so today Clara toss offers fast reliable
answers we have a test menu offering
over a hundred and ten tests currently
offered that are all DNA based tests
there's single gene tests that we offer
now and again our website offers the
list of these we offer our first
next-gen sequencing panel I say here as
dandy but it's really a neuro muscular
panel and we'll talk about that that's
at engene panel we offer a proprietary
CNB array that is optimized for really
defining regions that have been
associated or found causative in autism
we will be offering next-gen sequencing
exon based tests in the fall as we roll
out our strategy and our product menu
more completely through things like a
sthg and other meetings that will occur
and eventually genomes but I think what
we're aiming to do is use our essays use
the information in partnership with our
clinic clinicians are clear facility
using a variety of technology platforms
with the goal that we provide affordable
efficient and analytical services that
are scalable for using interpretation
provides important clinical context we
use experts for the bioinformatics from
Boston Children's Harvard Life
Technologies aiming to ensure consistent
scalable interpretation and our clinical
practitioners we have a client services
which are expert genetic counselors
medical directors that are overseeing
the clear laboratory and so forth and
again test menu all available but we
really operate in a collaborative way
with our partners so again test services
exone genome aiming to simplify but the
workflow really takes in a sample we
process if we analyze it and we report
it
so how do we do that again today we're
using the Ion Torrent platform today
we're offering our first next-gen
sequencing panel that we've validated
and verified in the production CLIA
laboratory we talked about the scale of
the eye on tour and being able in the
future to offer a genome to me today I'm
the thousand-dollar genome is a great
aspirational goal but today what I want
and I work with life technologies to
offer accurate clinical informative
sequencing using the ion proton starting
with PGM and now moving to the ion
proton they have a trajectory that is
exciting and it's why we think it's a
the optimal choice for a clinical
laboratory the workflow is simple the
data analysis is simplified the ability
to scale the workflow leading up to the
panels of genes that we will be offering
in the future you know scales of five
hundred and fifty to three thousand
genes is highly workable in a time frame
and a scale and a cost that's amenable
to clinical decision making following
the development of the sequence data
analysis processing signaling scoring
annotating and reporting again utilizes
the data that we generated from years
already but it will be building a new
database of knowledge and information
that we will continually be using for
reporting better and more informative
information for our patients and the
participants in the network we have
expert Tonetta counselors and medical
directors that review reports and help
in this interpretation again along with
physicians in our network we support a
very streamlined process helping the
physicians up front navigate the test
menu when doctors have patients with
complex presentation family history they
have a long-term relationship typically
we provide post
porting support reinterpretation
services as we incorporate new knowledge
into a test we did yesterday six months
from now and so forth and aiming to
really streamline your ordering an
integration into hospital systems is the
goal that we are aiming for we do not
have this available yet today but will
be growing navigating the menu again
taking the test selection tied to
clinical presentation how do we take
away some of the guesswork a fun
consultation to make sure the correct
test is ordered I think that in the
pediatric community clearly a world's
leading expert group like Boston
Children's Hospital will be much more
sophisticated in their knowledge of test
selection for on a phenotype such as
failure to thrive muscle weaknesses and
so forth but clearly the pediatric
community at large may and definitely
needs assistance in this and again we
aim to provide that for them for
hospitals again one-stop shopping how
does a laboratory how does a hospital
pediatric hospital in today's climate
really understand the best value the
best service the best test and what we
aim to provide is that one source for a
hospital for managing their send outs
for advising on testing for their
physicians and really helping them
navigate the complex landscape the kind
of investment that is required for next
gen sequencing is not able to be brought
to bear in every pediatric hospital and
every pediatric hospital may have
particular areas of expertise the Claret
Oz may not have and therefore as you
build a network there will be the
ability to to provide a one-stop shop
but through the network will be offering
services Eclair test would provide as
expertise but another Children's
Hospital may have an oncology expertise
for example and
you aim to partner together so that it's
seamless for the hospitals that are
ordering again I talked a little bit
about this a one-stop shop best value
integration today Hospital labs are
spending millions and many millions of
dollars to in some cases 50 to 60
testing laboratories for running DNA
diagnostic tests how do we work together
as individual and groups of institutions
that can now come together to better
leverage and better to go shave for
pricing eat a lot utilization guidelines
to be based on evidence and best
practices for the community and really
working together with some of the
largest providers testing services to
make this a seamless experience for the
pediatric hospitals again consolidating
molecular send out through a seamless
process for the hospital's payers want
utility and value and that's where by
building that knowledge through a
network we have the ability to go back
to the payers with this autism test is
the right test there's strong clinical
justification they're strong use and
there's a difference in how the patient
is treated again strong justification of
value test menu arises from clinical
needs emphasis on ordering the right
test and really trying to utilize and be
informative for cost savings so I wanted
to provide two examples of what we offer
today on today one of the first examples
I'd like to focus on is the example that
we have of an array based measurement
clearly something that's been used for a
variety of disease indications
particularly in oncology we have focused
again on the germline and looking at
copy number variations as they relate to
autism spectrum disorder and offer a
very unique proprietary product here
Clara toss this product that's used in
concert with a physician who sees a
patient with developmental delays
including autism is a product that has
been developed
you experience with looking at over
10,000 pediatric patients and allows the
customization of the ship to a number of
iterations to really maximize our
ability to detect copy number variations
in jeans that are so relevant for this
disease indication we've done a lot of
compare comparison to other products
that exist in the marketplace and we
believe we really have a superior
product for this area and we really have
worked with world-class physicians will
see these patients are genetic experts
and it really allows us to help inform
interpretation of our data that a
position would receive we are using an
Agilent of four by 180 k copy number and
snip array platform these are snips and
copy number probes cover the whole
genome what we've done uniquely is we've
shifted slightly and simply looking at
reg random snips across the genome to
really focusing in on regions that we
know are important for detection of copy
number variations so for example we know
that we've focused our CNB probes of
about 150,000 in regions of extreme
importance for copy number variation
that allows us to have exquisite
sensitivity and genes of interest when
we look at the coverage over clinically
relevant genes and we have a list of
some 811 genes that have shown clinical
relevance in this disease state that we
have very definitive ability to look at
copy number variations and genomic
imbalances in regions that are covered
on our chips we include telomeres
centromeres very much focused on the
clinically relevant genes and have
extremely good coverage to protect copy
number variation looking at 811 genes
versus a competitor's chip another
vendor that has 228 chains gently
covered for coffee number variation of
this particular phenotype we have unique
design features again that I said what
we've done is we've shifted some of the
snip probes that are sufficient to
detect regions of loss of heterozygosity
and so forth to maintain that but in
North particular probes from very common
regions of copy number polymorphisms
that exist in the majority of human
genomes that you would see and this is
based on three iterations of our chips
and so that we can shift that coverage
to regions that are particularly
relevant with uncovered and
developmental delay genes intellectual
disability autism spectrum disorders and
covering jeans for have Pablo
insufficiency I'd like to just show a
few examples and again the difference
being this is a particular gene that has
been shown to be implicated in autism
the nrx and one locus and you see the
very dense coverage that we offer across
the Clare toss on gene region for this
we show a patient's DNA and the dense um
coverage of this gene and the exons of
this gene and our ability to detect very
fine regions of deletion in this
particular patient sample same thing
this data has been published to show all
the different deletions we've identified
using this chip array and then again
other genes the STX be one locus again
dense gene coverage that allows you to
detect very small regions of deletion
and coverage across every exonic region
and the same thing with a fox g1 where
our ability is able to actually um show
in this gene which is a single exonic
gene the requirement for the detection
of a deletion in a copy number region is
a minimum of three to five Smith's that
our show a deletion and in ours we have
a total of sixteen probes that cover
this individual chain
and it allowed you very accurately show
the deletion of the Fox gene one gene in
patients that are missing this another
example that I'd like to highlight again
a unique product of claret oz is a
next-gen sequencing panel involved in
neuromuscular disorders and sequencing
of these genes on the background on
neuromuscular disorders in pediatric
patients for those who may not be as
familiar is it is a group of disorders
involving muscle and or direct nervous
system control of those muscles and
these neuromuscular disorders occur in
some 1.5 million Americans annually at
any age but importantly some forty
percent of this disorder is first seen
in pediatric patients under the age of
18 and these neuromuscular diseases are
quite progressive in nature resulting in
extreme muscle weakness fatigue and
could vary dramatically alter the
quality of life and do alter the quality
of life for both patients and their
families it is an active area of
research in rare disease therapeutic
discovery and development so I do think
there's a bright hopefully future for
understanding how best to deal with this
these disorders again um I'll refer to
it as MND on genetic disorders there's a
variety involved in a neuromuscular a
system there's a nice ncbi
classification of these diseases but
let's talk about how we approach genetic
testing in our CLIA laboratory it is
phenotypic driven so when a clinician
sees a patient I'm with presenting
systems that are diverse and could
include infantile on floppiness
hypotonia delay in walking feeding
respiratory difficulties of normal gates
cramps elevate creatine kinase levels
this is very much a sign and symptom of
neuromuscular disorder
and could lead to the need for a better
diagnosis of those symptoms through a
genetic tests such as our MMD panel this
is a panel now that we've developed in
concert with colleagues on Alan bags and
Luke oncol and our colleagues from the
DNA diagnostic laboratory here at bch
it's at engene panel uses next-gen
sequencing and it's available to the
community today the first thing we do in
detection of neuromuscular disorder as
many of these are caused by a neck sonic
deletion duplication of the Duchenne
muscular dystrophy gene or the MD gene
and so the first thing we do is we use a
allegation based probe detection very
simple assay to look for these large
deletions because approximately sixty
percent of these patients can be
classified as a DMD or the MD disease
relevant state by this first MLPs a to
accept to assess large exonic CNVs
following a negative result of that test
we would move then and that's just some
of the data but I want to move on it's
very easily detected following the
detection of that deletion the next
thing we would do or following the lack
of detection of a deletion or
duplication we would move to sequencing
of those genes using our panel which is
again at engene panel covering well over
a hundred 10 kb of gene sequence on
including a nut the genes depicted here
I'm for you and some large genes
included here we use an amplification
based method so we're using an amplicon
based sequencing method this has now
been very much optimized by um the life
technologies am plac'd exone product
however we developed ours first using
amplicon generation and automation
process for generating our sequencing
products and subsequent sequencing on
the Ion Torrent PGM instrument when you
look at this this is simply the coverage
one sample of this on a small PGM chip
on military inexpensive chip covers the
gene well over ninety six percent of the
gene at greater than almost you know
2000 x coverage so as we're using this
test in the initial stages were way over
covering we're validating everything we
find in the patient by Sanger sequencing
and building a large repository of
information on exactly the ability of
the Ion Torrent PGM to confirm with
Sanger data and in some cases actually
the ion joint on PGM does that open
sangha okay we did initial validation
studies and i just wanted to talk about
this initially obviously the first thing
we do in our research and development
team is develop a validation plan for
the assay the number of samples that
need to be wrong the number of mutations
positive samples that need to be Ron's
or confirmation multiple runs multiple
samples we ran a validation study to
assess the ability to identify 41
mutations none of those mutations were
missed however we had one interesting
mutation that was classified as
potentially missed it was a singing in
the Ion Torrent as a homozygote at a
particular position in a gene when we
reran the sang or which suggested it was
a heterozygote in fact it did confirm
that it was a homozygote so the UM the
PGN platform got that accurate again the
ability at the software to detect a
report in this case the variant is
reported in DD Smith as pathogenic in
its homozygote condition and not
neurosci code that's so that's a very
important correct classification based
on the header you know is it a
heterozygote is it homozygote and we did
get that correct as we went on saying a
confirmation of variance and this is
just a plot which shows are 15 patients
the number of sanger bearings that were
confirmed all were confirmed but we saw
a variety of variants and those are
interpreted in a report which had
clinical significance of the snip we
curate we query our existing database if
it's a novel we use informatics analysis
to actually help in the interpretation
of truly novel variants categorized we
score variants we have a reporting
template that we use and we really focus
very much on a high-quality clinical
services report back to the position for
this particular assay we've just
completed our first 11 clinical samples
now in the clear laboratory again I
realize a small number but this was a
just-released test we've identified one
patient with a multi exon deletion and
DMD again this is the first thing we do
three patients with pathogenic or likely
pathogenic variants in FK RP DMD and cap
and 32 patients with variants of unknown
significance and in the case of five
patients out of the 11 in which we had
no variant result that resulted in a
significant information in the genes we
surveyed in reporting back to the on
position so again on another aspect of
our limits to stop and see if there are
any questions also no questions we can
move on another aspect of the community
is really the research community and the
ability of the ability particularly in
the pediatric genomics community where
the individuals that you may see are
very sometimes really one unique patient
in your hospital and the ability to
think about
how you could coordinate efforts with
another hospital that might have seen a
similar phenotype and and the ability to
bring well-characterized samples
together to scale and enable discoveries
and that's through a research data
network that we are also aiming to build
with the pediatric on community and this
allows the creation of the data network
in which high quality data in a scale
before format is viewed as being
automated with bio via bioinformatics
ability to query and I would say this is
a much earlier phase in our company and
thinking about how we could use this and
leverage it to enable discovery but
we've had strong interest and the
pediatric hospitals that we've talked to
and we now need to think about how we
build this as a community again a data
network we need to ensure sorry that we
have a HIPAA compliant the consenting
IRB how do we share information how do
physicians researchers contribute their
data how do we structure the data how do
we best represent the samples with these
rare conditions I mean systems and
software to query and we've been
spending a lot of time looking at this
with some very exciting solutions
enabling really population-based
clinical pediatric studies the data
network again that we'd like to enable
global really working to enable research
that also would add to our knowledge of
clinical variants again imagine a
scalable clinical and research networks
we aim to really break down the barriers
in the pediatric hospitals aiming to
work together as a community
consolidation and lowering of tests and
really helping hospitals understand
where their area of expertise is where
our area of expertise is and with the
major investment that we've had from
life technologies really helping to
facilitate scalability and
sustainability as we really work at the
cutting edge of science and technology
in the clinical realm which really
ultimately is good for patients
so again a whole variety of the realm of
testing services ordering navigating
menus providing justification strong
clinical utilization and eventually a
research data scheme that we view would
really help bring the community together
for novel enhancing novel gene discovery
again I talked about this it's really
about the right question the right test
the right result really bringing
technology cutting truly cutting-edge
technology to the clinical scale today
which we are doing and enhancing our
ability to scale that and really offer
you know the next panel which will not
be 10 which will be 20 which will be 50
which will be 500 which will be 3000 so
we really have a very far-reaching view
and we'll be talking much more about
that over the coming months and with
that Clara toss genomics utilizing
genomics to enhance pediatric health I
will stop and we'll take questions but
I'd like to remind you that to obtain
continuing education credits you can go
to the bio conference live.com C and E
siiii I'm a link that will allow you to
address some of the questions that I've
prepared that will allow you to
demonstrate the knowledge that you've
obtained from today's discussion and at
this point we have time for questions
that i would love to entertain from the
audience and feel free to type your
questions and if not um either i've done
a good job or it's still a new learning
area for you so don't be shy to type
anything you're interested in
no questions it must have been quite
straightforward I guess son and and I'll
work with Don but I'm most curious about
our you know oh ok so I did get a
question so the question I was just
asked from joy at Columbus Technical
College is there a list of disorders
that you currently test for and I would
refer you to the claret oz genomics
website and look there at our test menu
right now it is not optimal for which
disorders although I think there's some
information that you can glean as to
which disorders or trying to optimize it
for being phenotypically driven rather
than we test for this gene which is
associated with this disorder but feel
free to take a look at that list and get
in touch with us if we can help you with
more information joy it is quite far
reaching I would say and it is unfocused
on you know gene sequencing arrays for
copy number and so forth I have another
question let me get to that question and
this is from of us at noble
International University and do question
was do you have any cooperation with any
research center in Canada today we do
not however we are talking to a number
of pediatric centers within the Canadian
community so be on the look for that as
we continue our discussions and we're
very actively doing so now
let's see who number three is oh thank
you very much I had a nice comment on
the fact that they are admiring the work
that we do and believe me when you walk
in you know right now we are still
located at Boston Children's Hospital
will be moving to Cambridge shortly but
when you walk in the doors of boston
children's hospital today you can really
understand why everyone who works at
clara tossed as a small company is so
passionate about what we do and the
excitement that we bring because we have
a lot to do um to solve the healthcare
challenges that are seen every day in
our children
looks like we have no more questions and
we're about out of time I'm happy to
stay and see if there are any more for
the next few minutes I don't mind the
silence because you may be thinking but
um it's an interesting format and I hope
it was informative for you and again you
can find our website don't hesitate to
get in touch with us that there's things
we can help you with we again this is
really our first opportunity to talk
about the company you'll see more from
us shortly in the coming month of
September and throughout as we continue
to launch new tests and really talk
about the work that we do
Oh